another massive street protests this in
northern Hong Kong thousands upon
thousands turned out to continue a
weekend of demonstrations against the
government here
what started as a protest against an
extradition treaty with China has
morphed into something far more serious
an actual questioning of what Hong Kong
actually is these people are peaceful
but not everyone is a breakaway group
the so-called black shirts attacked a
police station away from the main demo
it started with eggs and then bricks the
protesters often advancing under
umbrellas held up to protect their
identity this is designed to provoke the
police
although these groups have accused the
police of attacking them without reason
[Applause]
things are certainly escalating here
there's been violence but it's getting
worse news spread that the riot police
were on their way and the black shirt
melted away
what is certainly testing the patience
of the police is that there are multiple
demonstrations in many locations and
they last all day and night back on Hong
Kong Island riot police deployed to
protect districts that house Chinese and
Hong Kong government buildings
protesters had tried to reach here but
they were pushed away
the Blackshirts test them and then move
on they use the metro to move around the
island
it causes absolute chaos they literally
fill up the underground stations
ordinary tourists and shoppers can't
quite believe what they're seeing
thousands upon thousands follow orders
on social media and flock to where the
next location has been identified the
testers don't want to get caught by the
police because they'd be charged with
rioting and that carries a 10-year
prison sentence they've developed what
they call their guerrilla tactics they
go to an area they attack it and then
they use the tube cleared away so what
they're doing here to kind of Causeway
Bay big shopping area
they take over the streets and bring
tourists and shopping areas to a
standstill many here support the
protests but they don't like this is
something the Blackshirts understand
that they are unrepentant
we're not like targeting you know normal
people for no reason
the whatever that we're targeting is
actually very you know going on you know
the government buildings right whatever
symbols that represent the government
the police violence that's why we you
know go again go after thee any
indication is there any indication that
the government's listening TV absolutely
not a general strike on Monday and more
demonstrations in the days ahead are
planned Hong Kong's never seen anything
like this before
but everyone is bracing themselves from
all stevesie Sky News